okay earlier in the show I outlined five
lives that Donald Trump is already told
in his first three days as president of
the United States one that I alluded to
refer to this totally baseless fact lyst
debunked suggestion that Trump only lost
the popular vote on november eighth to
Hillary Clinton by nearly three million
votes because as he estimates 325
million undocumented immigrants voted
for Hillary Clinton and what's amazing
is Trump had his first official meeting
with congressional leaders yesterday and
he took the opportunity to repeat this
claim you show up a claim that you've
made on Twitter that's been fact checked
and judged as completely untrue by every
single reasonable fact checker and you
meet with congressional leadership and
what do you say hey guys by the way
remember I would have won the popular
vote were it not for 325 million people
voting for Hillary Clinton illegally
undocumented immigrants you know what
this shows to me Pat that Trump is very
very aware that many people see his
presidency as illegitimate for a number
of reasons not the least of which is a
nearly record loss in the popular vote I
think the fact that he lost the popular
vote is draining on him because before
the election I think at 2012 and then
even sense this 2016 election yeah he's
voiced the fact that yes the person who
gets the most votes should win I mean
that's the democratic way of doing
things right I think it's draining on
him he's tweeted numerous times that
we've got to do away with the Electoral
College which is the only reason the guy
one also congressman Steny Hoyer who's a
Democrat from Maryland he said he was at
the meeting he said not only did Trump
talk about the 325 million undocumented
immigrant votes he said Trump also
talked about the size of the crowd at
his inaugural address saying that you're
repeating these same debunked lies but
it was a record crowd a million to a
million and a half people this is what
Donald Trump is discussing in meetings
with other elected officials he seems
unbalanced and by the way Trump again
using undocumented immigrants as
scapegoats he's probably never going to
stop whining about this he wanted to win
the world's most important popularity
contest that's really why he ran for
president
and he actually lost that he lost that
almost three million more people voted
for the other candidate he's likely
going to whine forever about this yeah
these words are so out of place he went
in front of the CIA and talked about
crowd sighs and now he's going in front
of congressional leaders and talking
about the popular vote his arm it's like
he's still campaigning that's what he's
good at but it's time to move on and
start presidenting if you also apply
just a tiny bit of critical thinking to
the allegation that 325 million of the
11 million undocumented immigrants in
the united states voted illegally for
Hillary Clinton you're telling me nearly
half of undocumented immigrants in the
u.s. went out there to vote illegally
for a candidate that most likely was
just going to continue the Obama policy
which saw record deportations from 2009
to 2017 it doesn't pass the sniff test
pad why on earth would so many
undocumented immigrants even go out
there to do that risking exposing
themselves to deportation by showing up
at polls and trying to vote yeah we know
that voter fraud is statistically
insignificant and if you want to make
the case that there were 35 million
undocumented immigrants voting
especially in California provide some
evidence please yes at well that I would
love any evidence of this and there is
none because it's not true you would
have to be a [ __ ] to believe that this
is true but Donald Trump knows that with
him in this new world of Orwellian
alternative facts and untrustworthy
media even on just basic simple truths
if you say something as Donald Trump
many people will take it as I hate to
use this term gospel because the choices
I either believe what Trump says or I'm
going against our fearless leader who
will make America great again and he's
successfully conditioned his supporters
Pat to just believe whatever he says
it's brilliant what he's been able to do
and there's no signs of them deflect
defecting from Donald Trump Adele and I
think they're going to continue on that
train oh yeah they're there they're on
the nonstop to use Pat's train analogy
and there are very few stops at which
you can get off off of that train